[Music]
so
it's been nearly eight months since the
taliban regained control of afghanistan
or were basically handed it back by
president biden in that time women's
rights have been dragged back to the
dark ages afghan girls have been banned
from full education women are unable to
earn a living now for the first time in
decades all women are forced to wear the
islamic face fell the full burqa yet the
taliban says this is a measure to ensure
dignity and safety for their sisters
well joining me now for the first time
since these restrictions have come into
force is taliban official spokesman sue
hale shaheen mr shaheen thank you for
joining me
thank you
you made a promise you rang into the bbc
on august the 15th 2021 and you said
this i want to remind you of what you
said
they should not be scared
their honor
their properties their right to
education work as a
we have commitment for that
so they should not have
worries
their work
and
access to education
will be i think
more in a better position
than they were in the past
so that was you talking about women in
afghanistan and school girls and you
assured us that they would be in a
better position
than they were in the past but in fact
they've now gone back to the position
they were in when the taliban was in
charge before which is a position of
being oppressed
why is that and why did you lie about
improving a lot of women in afghanistan
your
first of all your
judgment is based on distorted reports
of media
right now
123 000
female students
and teachers
and government universities and private
universities
they are either working or receiving
education
mentioned that in your program about
four million female students in primary
schools they are going to school yes
right now if you're not in pakistan all
right mr zane let me jump in
let me respond to you let me respond to
you please don't just keep talking right
it is true that some primary school
girls are still going to school it's
after they get to teenage years it's
after they get to teenage years you have
stopped them going to school you don't
want girls in afghanistan to go through
full-time education that's not improving
the welfare and lifestyle of women in
afghanistan it's suppressing them why
don't you let secondary school age girls
go back to school
the secondary age school primary school
there are four million girls are going
to school now the issue of secondary
schools education for girls
they are
under consideration we have never said
they are banned
when you say that under consideration
what do you mean they're not currently
at school let them go back to school
just so you can all go back to school
that is why
we are uh talking
to work out our mechanism and we i hope
that you talk about this
there's nothing to talk about
a girl should be entitled to go to
school in afghanistan the same way a boy
goes to you yourself said in august last
year that they had nothing to worry
about nothing to be scared about so
because often to worry about let them go
back to school give them the education
that they were having give them the
education that they deserve
just do it stop telling them you're
under consideration
you've got to consider their right to
education
i said the girls have the right to have
access to education as boys i am saying
right now
that's why the the mechanism in
mechanism being workout
to provide a conducive environment
because it is islamic society there is
no question about their right to to go
to school
only there is some question again let me
jump in
let me respond to
[Music]
if there is no problem about their right
to an education let them go back to
school let me turn if i may
to the issue of the now compulsory
instruction for all women in afghanistan
to wear a full burka if they go outside
in fact there's an encouragement they
don't leave their home but if they do
leave their home they can only show
their eyes and if they get caught
showing any more than their eyes then
the male guardians who've been appointed
to basically enforce this
face going to prison this is
unbelievably oppressive way to treat
women in afghanistan after two decades
of experiencing a much freer society why
are you doing this when again by your
own words you promised they had nothing
to worry about
the abraham women
for centuries
they have been observing uh hijab
and they are our wearing hijab
voluntarily
so there is no addition
boredom on them and there there is
the statement doesn't say
is imposed or the only type of hijab it
says there are different type
hijab which are acceptable all right
okay
so just to be clear just to be clear
every woman in afghanistan right now can
go out and does not have to wear the
full burqa and she will get no
bad treatment from taliban is that
correct they're all free not to wear the
burqa is that your official position yes
just see
yeah yeah if they observe
hijab it may be a wheel it may be a
piece of cloth it may be a burka but it
is the burka is not the only type of
hijab it is clearly said any type of a
piece of clothing
she covers herself her body that is our
hijab so it is not the burka as you said
the decree that came down from the vice
and virtue ministry was that they were
not allowed to reveal more than their
eyes so whichever way you try and spin
this
that is a draconian measure which is
designed to suppress women more than
they've been used to in the last two
decades you're taking them back to what
life was like under taliban before and
i'm simply putting it to you that when
you took over the country again last
august you made a lot of pronouncements
for taliban that you were going to be a
different kind of taliban a more
inclusive taliban and that women had
nothing again back to your words nothing
to be scared about their honor their
properties their right to education work
and so on the kids after 12 13 can't go
to school all women have to wear a
covering apart from their eyes you know
they're not getting most jobs now apart
from women's specific
jobs which can't be filled by men they
have men now relatives and employers who
are exercising a control over them which
can be punishable if it's broken by
imprisonment this is incredibly
draconian i can't think of anywhere else
in the world that is doing this to women
and i just ask you again what part of
any of this
shows that you have changed the taliban
that you're more inclusive because i'm
not seeing any evidence that you're
doing anything other than taking women
right back to where they were
25 years ago
what you are seeing have gotten from
the media reports which are not correct
their property are safe secure
there's no problem with that
about
the the wheel it is not only in
afghanistan all over the islamic world
you may have it in uk the muslim women
are wearing also in uk
uh about
only opening the eyes
you
many are using the mosque there is no
problem it is the same as the mosque
you know yeah what's the problem now why
is that open so so
if i may say you're talking
draconian but
the wheel is doctronian
the taliban will be judged by their
actions and the reports from reporters
in afghanistan are completely contrary
to the picture that you're trying to
paint they are talking about women who
are now protesting in the streets
because they're being ordered to
completely cover themselves apart from
their eyes they're being told that male
relatives and employers are now
enforcing this on behalf of the taliban
so either they're all making it up and
they've all gone mad or the taliban
through people like yourself as a
spokesman are saying one thing in public
and a very different thing is happening
on the streets i want to talk to you
also about the economy in afghanistan
which is a complete disaster you now
have millions and millions of people
living in abject poverty in what way is
the taliban trying to improve the lives
of its people because it seems from
where i'm looking that ever since the
united states evacuated uh afghanistan
things have got immeasurably worse for
the people
why is that why given a second chance at
running the country have you so far
proven to be such abject failures
first of all i would like to say
99 percent of the women they are
observing hijab voluntarily
so
they consider it
a dignity
a safeguard for
their modesty modesty
secondly the poverty situation
uh the lack of job opportunity
opportunity is
because of the sanctions imposed
by international community
following our taking the capital kabul
so they are
punishing
the people of afghanistan
not the government by imposing the
sanction you can ask them why they have
done this why they are doing this to the
people of afghanistan so your position
is that the taliban has no
responsibility for the economic collapse
of the country and it's all everybody
yeah yeah yeah we have responsibility
what we have from our internal revenue
we are doing that uh in this we are
spending that in the service of our
people uh we are
starting uh development projects we are
paying the salaries of
the government employees who are about
500 000 from the pure previous
government they are still working in the
government we are doing that but we have
do not have
okay financially so strong to store all
the uh development projects some of the
projects which were funded by um some
countries they have been all right
i think 1990 personnel
it's a shame the truth is
afghanistan is in a terrible state right
now millions of people are living in
horrific poverty women are feeling
increasingly oppressed by the taliban
regime and my message to you simply
my message to you simply is if we take
you at face value then we should
expect that tomorrow secondary age kids
can go back to school and get a proper
education and if you say there is no
order for women to wear the full
covering and they can go out without
covering everything apart from their
eyes let's see that happen and let's
make sure that women that do express
that right and that freedom do not then
get punished we're going to leave it
there mr shaheen thank you very much
indeed for joining me yes i i i'm saying
right now that
the women in boys they have right to
have access to education that's only by
observing hijab yeah you don't have any
right to education if there's no school
you can go to our apartment has not said
that that denied that they're like we've
talked about
we've talked about this just for the
record you have two daughters do they go
to school
yeah of course yeah yeah
and really
of course they do because you're in they
can go to school right
and so well
that means we have not denied
daughters do foreign what you tell them
they're allowed to get okay so your
daughter's getting education because
wait a minute
your daughter's your daughter's getting
education because they do what you tell
them all right i'm glad we clarified
that uh sahil shaheen thank you very
much indeed for joining me well joining
me now is uh fauzio cuffi she was one of
the first female politicians in
afghanistan until she fed the country
last year when the taliban took over you
were shaking your head in derision a lot
of the stuff that he was saying there
clearly a lot of that is propaganda we
know from the reporting on the ground
what is going on in relation to
education of young girls in relation to
women and what they have to wear what is
your response to that in today
well peers i only hope that
there was a debate that he could listen
to and my message to him would have been
mr shaheen you and i negotiated for the
past three years
we started from moscow in february um
2019.
i remember as the first woman to
negotiate with you it was extremely
risky because i lost a lot of support in
my constituents by talking to you but we
did it for the sake of the country
because we wanted to come to a peace
deal remember there one of your uh
uh
i know you're doing it but he's gone
right i just wanna i mean so he can't
hear you so my point really is how much
of what he's saying is just propaganda
and nonsense from what you understand on
the ground i want to remind them because
i'm sure they will they will listen to
this that in that meeting one of their
negotiators say that
from their perspective women could go to
school could go to university could work
in business and politics could become
minister minister of foreign affairs up
to prime minister none of that's
happening
i'm quoting up to prime minister it was
a room full of men everybody looked at
me and said well miss goofy this is a
big news but in reality when they took
over power on the 15th of august the
first thing they did in contradiction
with islamic principles and what's
happening in the rest of muslim world
they stopped girls from going to school
only girls up to grade 12 go to school
this is not happening anywhere in the
world right anywhere they stop women
from going to work and you know what
these women actually were the bread
winners of their family they lost their
husbands in the war and they were the
supporters of their family they were
feeding their children with the money
that they were receiving through their
salary they cannot do it anymore because
they don't have a job to do it
now the last thing they did while the
country is at the age of starvation
economic crisis and people expect them
as people now in power to deliver the
last thing they did was another decree
asking women of afghanistan to wear
their favorite hijab which is burka now
let's remember that women of afghanistan
have always remained muslim and their
hijab the same way that i do is
acceptable in afghanistan by maine is
respected and this is part of our
identity we don't need taliban to come
and tell us that unless you don't wear
vel which is burka and it's even not
islamic it's
traditional are they there
member of the family will be punished so
can you imagine in a country which
already the rule of law is does not
exist the men are influencing and
committing violence well that's the
right that's the great irony is that the
men are now being told to enforce these
rules by the taliban and that in itself
is just utter misogyny
great to talk to you thank you very much
for coming in and just putting a woman's
perspective from afghanistan there i
think we all know what is happening on
the ground and it's completely
reprehensible the taliban are taking
these women back to a terrible time in
afghanistan's life and they've got to
stop it and the world needs to be
shining a light on this thank you very
much for coming in
uncensored next is the front man of the
sex pistols he spearheaded a generation
of young people clamoring for change
john lydon aka johnny rotten tells you
why he claims he's being censored after
the break
[Music]
this is talk tv
former sex pistols front man johnny
rotten has never been afraid to speak
his mind but now he claims he's been
cancelled by his former band there were
a new biopic called pistol and ordered
not to say anything negative about it
before i speak to him here's the band's
anthem god save the queen which has been
re-released ahead of the queen's
platinum jubilee
[Music]
[Applause]
john let me talk to you first of all
about this issue over the uh this series
is coming out on disney plus about the
sex pistols you know when y'all watch
that clip you you guys really were one
of the all-time great bads not for very
long the longevity of the band but you
were magnificent and it seems entirely
right and proper that there should be
this series but you've fallen out with
the band members over it why
uh because they put it together behind
my back without mentioning it to me at
all until january the fourth last year
then we got an email from danny boyle on
the 8th saying that he would like to
discuss it with us
and on the 9th ninth
over the weekend the press were banging
on my door
and on the the following monday
uh it was released all over the internet
as a done and dusted deal actors were
appointed scripts were written plots
were
fully fully covered but without me so
this tv series they could call it a
documentary i prefer mockumentary uh
it's completely without me contributing
in any way shape or form and i don't
think to be absolutely honest anyone
could ever consider the sex pistols
without the man what wrote the song
right
well i completely agree i mean
it's a great shame because danny boyle
is doing it he's a top director you know
i don't know have you seen any of the of
the series
no i haven't been allowed to see
anything at all
no scripts nothing
do you know any
it would have been a fantastic
opportunity to really grasp and and
enjoy the truth of that situation but i
think they've gone for this uh watered
down kind of cop-out that isn't going to
do anybody any good
actually what they're doing is
destroying the sex pistols which is a
great great shame and you know i was
reminded of the sex because when you
when you see that magnificent anthem
which got everyone going and got banned
and the rest of it god saved the queen
at the time you know it was back at the
silver jubilee 1977 and at the time it
was a kind of rant against the monarchy
you were young and knarking punks as
you've got older uh john have you
suffered your view of the monarchy and
the queen
pierce
let someone talk i didn't write it
specifically for the jubilee that was my
train of thought and it was some several
several months
before we did that boat party
um
it's it's very anti-royalist but it's
not anti-human
right
i've got to tell the world this you
mustn't presume that i'm completely dead
against the royal family as human beings
i'm not i'm actually really really proud
of the queen for surviving and doing so
well i i applaud her for that that's a
fantastic achievement i'm not a
curmudgeon about that i just think that
if i'm paying my tax money to support
this system i should have a say so on
how it's spent and do you think john
do you think possibly the end of the
monarchy because prince charles is not
going to be able to handle it this is
the man that plays pink floyd to his
cabbages
that
so you think we might be seeing the the
beginning of the end of the monarchy as
the queen enters the sort of twilight of
the light possibly possibly possibly
that's a shame in itself too because uh
i do love pageantry you know i mean
i'm a football fan how could i not you
know
i like uh i like watching royal weddings
because i really did enjoy watching
spitfires and b-52s and the likes flying
over the palace i get i get quite
emotional with all that yeah i love my
country i love me people and everything
about it but if there's problems within
it i think i have the right to say so
and when i wrote god save the queen and
believe me i wrote it not not the others
right
this is me expressing my fully competent
point of view what do you make john what
are you making you're more than welcome
to disagree no no no it's all your
titles your opinions this show is called
piers morgan uncensored
i absolutely want an uncensored john
lydon what do you think talking of being
uncensored about megan and harry and
their contribution to the royal debate
at the moment i
i i'm sorry but i think that they've uh
showed themselves to be uh parasites if
you want to opt out of that family
situation then please by all means do
and go and work for mcdonald's but don't
expect me to be still forking money out
to support your nonsense
they seem to be amazingly ungrateful at
least he is
right and as for the sex scandals
involving the other son well you know
les said best said until that turns up
in call
i think uh as as public figures if you
don't want to be a public figure then
shut your mouth
[Laughter]
what do you make john of the it was a
survey came out today about
woke and wokeness 36 of the public
apparently in the uk think the woke is
an insult but 26 percent think it's a
compliment do you identify as woke
it well certainly not my advice to the
woke is to please wake up
it's uh it's a lot of uh
typewriter warriors on the internet
isn't it doing this stuff and creating
idolized fantasies for themselves in in
the privacy of their own bedrooms that
their mum and dads are paying for and
unfortunately uh left-leaning
politicians have grabbed on to that and
seen that as their new potential
uh voter base
and that's where it's going wrong
because once politicians uh declare
themselves as woke well we're all doomed
the reason i love you
i think it's a current i think it's a
current fashionable trend that will end
very very sadly for them because it
really is all about being selfish yeah
and ultimately if the ambition is that
we're all woke then you've achieved
nothing
yeah i agree i mean the thing i love
about you john and i'd say this was
great sincerity whenever i've
interviewed you you are literally
uncensored and uncensorable no one has
ever told you what you can and can't say
and you wouldn't listen to them if they
did but so many people now including
many people in the music industry are
terrified of saying the right thing in
the wrong thing worried about being
cancelled by this canceled culture what
do you make of the fear that everyone's
now living in
well i i think that that shows you that
a lot of people don't actually know how
to think
i i don't just jump to conclusions i
spend most of my life studying and
observing my fellow human beings so i
tend to know what i'm saying
it's not just sloganeering for me or
trying to jump onto a bandwagon
and that's how it should be for all of
us
let all those that follow the nonsense
sync with that ship now john i wanted to
just end by mentioning that madonna
another sort of bad
bad rebel of of music if you like
has released some nfts these
non-fundable whatever they are tokens uh
of apparently of scans of her genitals
and what i wonder was whether you might
be bidding for them
[Laughter]
i i think if my memory serves me well
i've seen the real thing and i never
ever want to be reminded
online as always nft
yeah nft's interesting to me because i'm
getting i'm getting involved in it
myself because i'm a bit of a painter on
the side and i'm raising money for
alzheimer's victims for an organization
called spitz out of islington you know
the area i was brought up in um and
we'll be sending musicians to the local
care centers brilliant and uh and
because music as i well know my wife
with alzheimer's now music helps her
brain open up and gets her thinking
don't let people with alzheimer's sit
and vegetate involve them in things yeah
and so yippee i found a way to do that
not only for my own wife but with other
people and also i'll be planting trees
all over ireland because there's too
many golf courses
and that's an organization yeah it's an
organization called paramilitary
john unfortunately we are running out of
time but finally i wanted to ask you one
question if you could relive one moment
from your time with the sex pistols
right now which moment would you choose
uh
i suppose uh the first day's rehearsal
all right when i i
became alarmingly aware that these lads
really hadn't much going for them and i
had a golden opportunity to use all the
writings and thoughts i had in my head
and put it to music and that was just a
most fantastic rewarding feeling now
anybody looking back at the pistols
please remember with fondness just how
vital and important we were not this new
nonsense
john you were vital you were important i
think you still are vital and important
you're a fantastic guest on any show
like this always it's great to talk to
you and all the very best to you and to
your wife
made a road voice with you and your
enemies always be behind you major
scattered flatter battery chatter
[Laughter]
john lyden thank you great to talk to
you
and since the next new king of late
night ustv greg gutfeld is here tell me
if we've all completely lost our sense
of humor that's coming up
[Music]
do
welcome to the uncensored comedy club
where no topic is off limits and we
laugh when do we all lose our sense of
humor well one person who hasn't is
comedian ricky gervais when asked on
twitter yesterday what he thought about
me interviewing the taliban officials
spokesman he said i've lost all respect
for them it was a gag a lot of half
which didn't get the gag
why why have i lost the ability to
understand humor in a moment i'll speak
to one of the funniest men in america
great gut fell but first let's see him
in action
so it's 2021 and this monologue is on
the steele dossier like a birthmark this
story never ever goes away is that my
fault no i would much prefer to do
something on joe biden breaking wind at
the climate summit
that breeze was so hot greta thundberg
asked him to stand in front of a
windmill
[Applause]
but look that fart was the only honest
thing to come out of joe since he became
president as you know hillary clinton is
on her please don't forget me tour now
showing up on a late night show to crack
wise about the guy who shellacked her
like a driftwood sculpture in 2016
yes trump is her meal ticket her free
bird her stairway to heaven she brought
chelsea because she's also unemployed
and bill wanted both of them out of the
house before his 5 pm shows up her
name's crystal
well greg garfield george greg brilliant
to have you on piers morgan uncensored i
have a great time with you in new york
doing the the five the show that you're
the superstar on your own shows on the
biggest show on cable in america
congratulations i want to take you back
thank you i'll take you back to a quote
that you said which i thought was really
pertinent to the time we live in he said
i became a conservative by being around
liberals i became a libertarian by being
around conservatives you realize there's
something distinctly in common between
the two groups the left and the right
the worst part of each of them
is the moralizing and i i thought that
was so pertinent to what goes on now
especially on social media
absolutely the uh
one of the greatest things that the woke
has done is that they've made
humorlessness hilarious so what i was
talking about is like
when you're around the left and they
they're so earnest and sanctimonious and
yet they get nothing done you drift away
then you get into the conservative realm
and you have the same kind except they
might be more religious more moralistic
in a different way and you and you move
into the libertarian world but then even
you in libertarians you find some
humorousness there but what wokism has
done for all of us and has united up
like left and right and center is they
have taught us how humorlessness is the
funniest damn thing on earth they i mean
the only reason why my show was a hit is
because of them
right cancel culture locism i don't have
to i don't really have to do that much
work peers which is kind of my goal in
life all i got all i got to do is go on
twitter you find the most extreme idiot
which is about ten percent right of
twitter and then let them do the work
for you they do the heavy lifting with
their you know their twisted mindset i
mean he wants it
it was hilarious last night i
interviewed the official spokesman for
the taliban and somebody tweeted ricky
gervais to say isn't it disgusting that
piers morgan's doing this and gervais
replied i've lost all respect for them
the taliban right of course it's just a
simple gang but absolute mayhem erupted
because most of twitter did took him
seriously so i saw that ricky gervais
tweet
the stuff that didn't bother me was the
people who didn't get the joke it was
the people that explained the joke there
was like a david like there was like
david bedeal
is that his name david badil
he's british yeah he was like trying to
just go oh here's why this joke is so
good and then he goes on to explain it
and it's like oh god so you have in
twitter you have joke explainers you
have the humorless the humorless
contingent which is probably now
probably about 25 percent so but it's
just what you have to live with i find
that to be in my opinion more enjoyable
than the actual
legitimately funny people i mean without
wokism and without the humorlessness we
wouldn't have you know tidiana mcgrath
well this one
this brings me to
two of my favorite subjects of humor
actually which is megan and harry who
are planning to come and hijack the
queen's platinum jubilee and i know you
find them a constant source of hilarity
as well they don't ever intend to make
us laugh they just make us laugh
throughout the world i got it
i
love
that her woke cartoon on netflix got
cancelled there's a there's a great
story behind this the cartoon is called
pearl it's about a coming of age right
which is which is uh uh a code word for
nauseating you know self-involved tripe
so what happened is did they think this
is my favorite part so it's like a young
girl's
rise in social justice and you know who
you know who megan's cartoon is inspired
by
megan
she made the car it's inspired by her
which is amazing and it but that's that
tells you everything that in the woke
world it is not actually about helping
people it's a disguise it's a virtue
signal that helps you that makes you
look good right and there's perfect
evidence of this because they never help
anybody but themselves and they never
fail they don't even change course yeah
they never me they never mean it it's
never about actually anything but
enriching themselves and making
themselves look exactly i'm preaching
one thing
i resent england for sending your
second hand royalty to us because now we
got to deal with this
hang on hang on to be fair you lot sent
two women into our royal family one of
them led to an abdication
and the other one has nearly broken up
the entire monarchy so with respect to
you america you're two for two and it's
not looking good
yes i just love the fact that they
thought that they were going to be
royalty here in america so there was an
assumption that when and they were
almost there i mean they were going to
get gigs everywhere there you know there
were netflix hulu apple tv everybody was
just going to give them millions of
mills and then they had to sit in a room
with them and realize my god they're
vacuous
he's a nice guy apparently but i mean to
thoroughly evacuate she leads him around
on a rope and you know and it's like
that's it it that is the kind of sitcom
i want to see i'm telling you this is a
reality show what i mentioned to we do a
nightly thing called the world's gone
nuts and i want to just go into this one
with you i'll clip my fingers and show
you
[Applause]
apologies for the american accent there
greg but this is a such a brilliant
story it sums up the world we live in
scientists have declared that there is
sexism in the naming of parasitic worms
a team of scientists has concluded that
there were apparently uh
596 new species of parasitic worms and
of those only 111 18 percent honored
female scientists
therefore they wanted an end to this
epidemiological nepotism and cronyism
and sexism in other words they want more
parasitic worms to be named after women
otherwise it's sexism
you know what i'm gonna go you know this
this
i'm so tired of ships being named after
women now they want our worms they want
our worms pierced
it's like by the way by the way has
anybody talked to the worms how do the
worms feel well exactly you know by the
way by the way if they had
if they hadn't named every parent any
worm after women the women would have
gone nuts saying why are you calling us
all after paris any worms
and how does a worm feel being called a
parasite a parasite is not a nice word
why don't you call them adjunctive
livers like or uh
adjacent
adjacent survivalists
because i mean
parasitic it's just so mean-spirited
worms have feelings too i could talk to
you uh for a very long time i know that
you you made yourself the biggest star
on american tv because you just laugh at
all this nonsense it is all nonsense uh
and the world has gone nuts but thank
god you're here to help try and save us
greg gutville thank you i appreciate you
coming up
that's it from me i'll be back on monday
whatever you're up to this weekend make
sure it's uncensored
[Music]
i'm julia hartley brewer and this is
talk tv i think my most memorable and
proudest moment in journalism of all
these years it's actually being on air
during the lockdowns even when i had
coveted myself over the last two years
getting people to tell their stories not
just about people who lost loved ones to
covet but people lost their fundamental
freedoms their children's schooling
their mental health their physical
health their businesses and giving
people the chance to tell their stories
about how it affected them
[Music]
i'm tony dunn and this is talk tv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i had no idea what he
did is he went on one of the more moves
he's going to launch a nuclear strike on
north korea or open up a shark pit that
i then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and he walked a
butler with a tray and carrying a dark
hood
here's the diet coke
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm emily rose adams
ukraine's defense minister says he hopes
to arm a million fighters as the country
prepares for a new long phase of war in
a post on facebook he said ukraine is
facing extremely difficult weeks ahead
but with patience they will win
colleen rooney has revealed details of
her marriage issues with wayne in day
four of the wagatha christie trial she
told the high court that articles about
her and her husband affected their
relationship rooney's being sued for
liable after accusing fellow wag rebecca
vardy of leaking stories about her to
the press
and just days after missing the state
opening of parliament the queen's been
pictured at the royal windsor horse show
today it's her first public appearance
since the duke of edinburgh's memorial
service back in march
that's all for now we'll have more news
updates after the talk
[Music]
this